Thousands of infants in Brazil are being diagnosed
with a devastating birth defect and medical
researchers believe it might be linked to
a mosquito borne virus.
So, what is this mysterious virus and how
do we stop it?
Zika, a strange mosquito borne virus, is sweeping
through many Central and South American countries.
Current estimates place the number of Zika
cases at over a million in Brazil alone.
And in response to the outbreak the CDC has
implemented two new travel bans, to an already
large list, for pregnant women, one on the
United States Virgin Islands and the other
on the Dominican Republic.
The ban is for pregnant women specifically
because since the epidemic started, the incidences
of microcephaly, a devastating birth defect,
have skyrocketed.
Microcephaly is a condition where a baby is
born with a small head.
Because the head is so small in those born
with the condition, the brain is small too,
meaning it’s underdeveloped.
Which can cause a whole range of other health
issues like cognitive deficits, seizures,
feeding problems, vision problems and hearing
loss.
Unfortunately there’s no cure for the condition,
only treatments for it’s effects.
Microcephaly is typically seen in rates of
about 2 in 10,000 births according to a study
published in the journal Birth Defects Research
(Part A).
But nearly 4,000 cases have been reported
in Brazil since October, that’s nearly 26
times the normal rate.
And researchers strongly suspect that the
birth defect is linked to the Zika virus.
Now this epidemic seemed to come out of nowhere.
The mosquito that carries the virus, Aedes
aegypti, was pretty much eradicated in Brazil
in the 1950s.
But as the decades wore on, it made it’s
way back.
Then last year reports of Zika in Brazil started
popping up.
But it wasn’t taken too seriously, since
it’s symptoms are mild, just things like
a fever or a rash.
It wasn’t until the rate of Microcephaly
shot up that the world started to take notice.
Now the battle against Zika is underway, and
one that Brazil is badly losing, according
to the health minister.
And it is literally a battle, 220,000 members
of the armed forces are going door to door
to help in the current mosquito eradication
efforts.
But it’s not just Brazil, Zika has been
reported in 24 regions around the world, mostly
in tropical areas.
Each country is issuing warnings, some seem
extreme.
For instance, the government of El Salvador
told women to avoid pregnancy for two years!
As for the zika virus itself, there’s no
treatment, vaccine, or cure.
The CDC says the best way to avoid the virus,
is to avoid mosquito bites.
Now, experts say that a US outbreak is unlikely
to occur.
They believe that most cases will happen to
those who travel to Brazil and other affected
countries.
But this summer tons of people will descend
on Rio de Janeiro for the 2016 Games.
Which some experts are calling “a perfect
dissemination vehicle for Zika.”
If people travel to Brazil, get zika from
a mosquito bite, then return home and get
bitten there, the zika virus could transfer
to the local mosquito population.
Which would mean that there is the pot